[Applause]
welcome to the col show
everybody give it up my man
y'all Chie with her vog at the end I
liked it I liked it you look ready for a
music video it's nice that was Madonna's
1990 classic vog if I needed to tell you
that what that obviously everybody knows
that but we just did it to be kind I
guess uh this is so cool though when she
kicked off her celebration tour in
London this year her youngest daughter
aair showed up on stage during this
photo um and EST went all out with a
Vogue dance performance that made her
family so proud as you can see from the
bells jingle
bells jingle all the way happy holidays
everyone
ohing jingle bell jingle all the
way oh what fun it is to ride
open happy
holid I was like what the
hell wait what are you doing Sterling
came Brown
everybody thank you everybody what are
you doing here listen uh I'm Z town to
promote my new movie American fiction oh
my out of New York in La December 15th
out it's all good but I came I come
bearing gifts okay take a look open that
top right there
yes you remembered I
remember remembered how do I how do I
like to eat these so if you guys don't
know Kelly enjoys Doritos but not the
whole Doritos no she just likes to lick
the dust off the Dorito and then throw
it away so yeah it's an addiction you
could you going to try to whole chip
this time or maybe I'm going to do it
right now I'm are you really wait wait
wait wa
you should try it you try it just the
dust just the dust the dust uhh it's not
going to
look it's so
good it so good it is and then you toss
the cookie you TOS yeah I'm just saying
it's I don't know if I have some kind of
salt thing I don't know what happened I
really like wait wait you're you're
you're here you're promoting I love this
building so much random people stop by I
love it so much don't wait what's the
what are you promoting what are you
doing right now I'm promoting a movie
called American fiction yeah right
starring Jeffrey Wright Erica Alexander
uh Tracy Ellis Ross myself Isa Ray Etc
wow it opens December 15th in New York
and la and then it rolls out nationwide
at the beginning of 2024 please come out
and support wait those are amazing
acting what what is it about what is it
about it is about it is about a writer
who is frustrated black writer who's
getting frustrated because he wants to
write different things but the only
thing that America seems to want to see
has to do with people in Dire Straits
that look like me so he writes something
as a spoof about people in Dire Straits
that look like as a joke and it becomes
like his bestselling novel ever of it's
a comedy check it out please it's kind
of a comedy but kind of not it's kind of
all of that was like but kind of really
sad and we need progress Kelly claron
you look good thank you I say Kelly
claron look good I love that you I love
that you st by and you brought a
Christmas TR course you can't come
empty-handed that's what my mom told me
I you I got you to do it I got you to
try it you were like this is gross I
lick the chip no it was tasty it's so
good it's really good man I could do the
whole bag come okay okay oh my gosh okay
so American fiction right amican fiction
December December 15th New York and
everybody I love you for stopping by to
you and you sing a hell of a jingle bell
stop you look
everybody
B
wait wait thank you br that was well
that was awesome I love this building so
much you have no idea what will happen I
love that he brought me Doritos and I'm
look I'm really weird but I don't know
if there's like a deficiency of I don't
know what's happening but just try it
it's so good just both SIDS you don't
need the chip it's like less less
caloric intake is all I'm saying but
your tongue does feel like a cat by the
time you're done you know that weird
yeah anyway no one's kissing me I don't
care um let's bring up or more like I
ain't kissing anybody anyway
soy I'm just kidding I'm so weird
[Music]
okay
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home